I love it by the way Halloween did not
love it why not I was cut out of it
worried oh yeah who'd you play so I go
Myers he I was Michael no I was Magog
directed David Gordon Green I had done
another project with him and he asked me
if I want to come in and play a cop and
that's how I know I'm old now as I'm
playing roles that have careers very
distinct what do you want me to be like
teenage so uh so I was playing a cop
that had like a beef with the you know
the the young girl her boyfriend I mean
safely in it yeah so he was like a major
part of the movie and they like cut him
did they yeah so my scene was with with
him and kind of her peripherally and
they basic call me up he's like dude we
had to cut the kid and you're seeing was
with the kid I wonder why they cut so
much of his stuff I think to keep it
down oh I think movie was fat it was
already over two hours yeah oh yeah
Halloween was two hours know if it was
playing an hour and 40 maybe I maybe
there were a lot of previews oh yeah
because I we have a 7:15 movie I went
out by 9:15 is part when T minutes of
previews I I liked it I just you know I
just why didn't you love it because I
didn't care that much I didn't like his
dumb beard from the side it to me it
didn't like the mask whose feared from
the side Michael Myers you didn't like
being beard yeah guessing that first
scene it annoyed me for some reason why
I just because it just didn't I know
it's an hour forty for you I didn't like
it on his face and I had a beard I just
stupid do you didn't like the beer
eating there about the beer both didn't
like that you didn't care about the beer
I hate it
I just behind the mask by the way yeah
that's a good point but there's a beard
under it 85 to 90 90 I'd say 90% of the
movie he had a mask but I knew
disappeared I was bothered that he
wasn't clean-shaven I'll tell you I
don't know why it bugs me but the whole
idea
[Laughter]
we're seeing a [ __ ] beard why the
guy's shaved before the dead mascot
I just didn't it didn't it didn't take
me it didn't teach me anything about
Michael Myers there wasn't yeah the
beard you learned it wasn't you that
there was no different moment that I had
wanted like I wanted something some
connection to Lori because he's wanted
to kill her for all these years I give
me an ex place and then he's just a dumb
machine again all right we get it
some of the killing stuff was great I
thought that the beard humanized him I
didn't care because what beard has it
what machine has a beard and I
understood that he was humanized by that
but the just the idea that he would
hunted this woman and it meant something
what did it give him and then we learned
zero about him it was like what should I
do an impression of Michael Myers
there's no personality to him at all it
was never personality of Michael I know
that but if you're bringing him back 40
years later I'll he he's been hunting
here for four years and I hated her
meltdown oh god she's a drunk just
[ __ ] move get out of that dumb town
but that's the point you're supposed to
not like the field field whatever it is
you're supposed to move [ __ ]
she's not then I go down into the
basement then she comes back up make up
your mind you're in the basement but
they had to get him in the nobody didn't
just shoot him he gets up from shooting
that's the point the house is built for
that's why I hated that the dumb house
was built for that I shouldn't be
surprised that Jim doesn't like you
can't shoot him that's the whole point
of the hit him with the car and he fell
down and then he got back up they could
have just burned him will Patton was
gonna fake it burn him in the house
no well spoiler alert well Patton was
gonna put a bullet into his head and the
cop the cop he was also a great movie
called no way out yeah with Gene Hackman
you see that he played the little the
guys Pritchard or whatever who was gay
David okay guy who Gene Hackman betrayed
the end he's nobody saw that movie
diddy album that's Jim the reason you
saw the beard we say you could be
reminded of the scar next to his eye the
reason you saw the scar next to his eye
is so you could be reminded that the
before he was in the mental institution
in clap-clap he got shot in the face
already yeah I don't care you can't sit
there and be like why didn't you just
shoot him because Laurie Strode has been
obsessed with this guy for dinner and
she knows shooting isn't gonna kill her
spend all of it and I understood it we
learn that the only thing keeping
Michael Myers alive and the only thing
keeping Laurie alive is the
predator-prey relationship but there was
no judgment with them which this is what
annoyed me yeah there was no moment with
them where it meant anything to me I
didn't give a [ __ ] it was love at first
too but this point is 40 years later
they're bringing it they're trying to
humanize him in some way slightly not
much but then there's not one
interesting moment of his humanity like
there's it wasn't supposed to be he is
in essence nothing that made me give a
[ __ ] like some of the killing was really
good you wanted to sympathize with
Michael not sympathize with him but have
some moment where something was
different than it was there's a more
effective tool Thanos and the Avengers
they made him very understandable but
he's a being he's a presence this is
completely why did he break out of the
hospital mr. hot [ __ ] he just sat in the
hospital like a curse for 40 years
here's away that he's chained up well I
bet he can't get shot with the chain he
can't unplug undo a chain or [ __ ]
throw a guard through the window
you know how they humanized them how he
didn't kill the baby he didn't kill the
kid in the thing I saw that humanized
shirt was no yes
that was them saying Kara kids you're
likable Joe Pesci casino that's right
that was them saying we can't kill a kid
because no one will go with this movie
if he kills the baby
now I don't think that that's real
Packer he's the guy kind of speaks like
- a little bit he was in Armageddon
right that's will patent patent patent
pact nope no yeah PA tto and he was the
cop in the movie right and are we
getting you uh it's no way out too when
we're in no way out so when we're
shooting the scene I had a real cop take
with me that was also like a cop right
okay and he goes I love that guy will
patent funny story uh once I pulled him
over on when he was driving down here
and he was shit-faced man but uh I love
that Armageddon movie saw I just told
him you know be safe I go you want to
meet him he goes he goes yeah love to
meet him
I go hey well as a guy who's you know
doing a scene in the movie he just wants
to say hello and we'll look soon lead us
hey how do I know you and he goes I
don't know you know I mean one time I
think I pulled you out you pulled me
over and didn't give me a ticket cuz
you're a fan of armed again so you're so
good at see no way out with Gene Hackman
and Kevin Costner and Shaun young but
way seven nobody's gonna watch it
they're all in a lot
not one person is listening to this show
is gonna watch more moisture their movie
taste - we just listen to him play video
games I think we could watch no way
nobody's watching no way out nobody
nobody saw pick up 52 or whatever your
52 pickup Rider and Marcus Lawrence
Williams the third nobody's interested
you have like a real nuanced view of
this movie and the beard lets you to the
scar and he's just like he's dumb and I
and I didn't buy the fact that stupid
Michael Myers would put him in to kill
the two cops in the car and make a
display out of them why wouldn't he
because he can't drive and by the way
that's dumb Laurie dumb Laurie got her
whole [ __ ] for forty years have been
training to shoot she has one shot at
this idiot and she hits his shoulder and
then turns around to talk to somebody
how do her in the cop who's Michael
Myers walking out of the house you don't
like that many like that towards the end
of the move
we started to realize that positioning
between who Michael Myers was and who
Laurie was started changing they didn't
we tell you how he even knew her it's
not her brother it's her brother makeups
cannot run mine they ignored that why
why do they ignore that it's not a
brother they didn't directly equal to
the first here's why that's Norden
number one it happened write up the
number two never happened they didn't
ignore it they addressed it by saying I
heard that they were brother and sister
no that's [ __ ] that was there where
does he want to kill her so of letting
the audience know number two never
happened then why does he want got away
she got away
she was the survivor and that's the
point good why is this happening is what
fuels us it's what fuels the
relationship did nothing it's the Batman
and Joker there would be it but there
was no by the end of it the
predator-prey relationship left us all
in question after who is the predator
here is it here's why it doesn't match
my whole review and Sam why it matters
me because there's been so many Michael
Mayer movies yeah and he's the same
[ __ ] quiet dud in everyone I love him
but he's the same it's like now that
you're doing this this 40 years later
sequel give me something that I haven't
seen since 1978
do you know me one even have something
to talk no not talk I don't why why he
was the doctor hated that dumb character
- he's a [ __ ] an SNL character of a
doctor but the dumb scalpel shut up do
you understand the the outrage and
contempt that would be felt for this
movie if Michael Meyers were presented
anything other than know just the
essence of it was one - aha Jim feels
about things he hates okay I wanted one
moment of him of recognition not of
speaking but of something right why
because something is motivating him
something is moving him he's not that
[ __ ] evil because he couldn't break
out of the hospital without them doing a
[ __ ] transfer he was waiting for the
perfect what if she got [ __ ] cancer
and dropped dead in 1987 then what would
he had done he would I'd he would have
killed maybe you would have died maybe
you would have gone and killed the dog
but it's not
he's evil personified yeah why is he
only directing that evil at her question
give me a reason why he is tied to like
I know why the Joker's tied to Batman
Batman is I'm gonna do all good I'm not
gonna kill anybody
Joker is I just want you to kill someone
you want me to stop kill me he's the one
that got away and it's not like it's
only directed towards her he kills a ton
of you to get to her thing yet but he
would still kill those people
he wouldn't kill him anyway I just there
was something what if he wouldn't I mean
what if my if my what my aunt had it my
uncle you know what if he's Dill's her
he's done with killing you think he's
gonna do more killing after killing her
that's the question we all ask isn't it
but I think she's the reason everyone's
dead maybe kill yourself kill yourself
Maury yeah yeah burn yourself to death
drinking the stop such a flawed
character no I didn't care she was a
terrible mother
that to me what that was the same as
baby driver having tinnitus oh they were
just little interesting things they
threw in to make it a deeper it's
character development no I don't eat sit
by for me character that's my but
tonight was about not wanting to write
dialogue that could also be right there
with him like I like this song since
it's fast and furious
I would like Michael Myers who had one
moment of recognition one moment of
something he's not a man he's not a
person why did they gather at mental
hospital brings up he brings up the
knife and then all of a sudden he sees
his reflection in the knife or he does
come self aware and then Laurie goes
Michael I am your father
but that to me made Darth Vader much
more interesting when there was some
moment that was different than the first
one I think anybody that listens to this
show is aware do you have an affinity
for Darth Vader who doesn't Andrew to
bring you up to speed a bad guy Jim
thinks that all the new Star Wars movies
are [ __ ] because Darth Vader Jim's right
I want you on kadjar kylo Ren is a piece
of [ __ ] because Darth Vader's not who's
that [ __ ] all I have daddy issues he
stunk that [ __ ] bad guy a [ __ ] key
I don't want to tear to drop down a
[ __ ] Internet intergalactic
supervillain who do you like Darth Vader
and I like the [ __ ] you know the old guy
the Emperor right I'm just like out your
kids Garrett of both of them yeah it was
good all right you know Peter Cushing I
loved in the first one what's your
favorite movie monster not villain
monster of the of like the of the new
not like the universe or my about saying
else did you like Dana's fancy him ah
I think he'd like Dana's favorite movie
yeah because you could you could argue
that he's not even I wouldn't say Valen
like he's you know he's one of those
justified by Christopher Lee from
Dracula Dracula has risen from the grave
what about like of Dracula no no Dracula
like movie monsters that are like that
wasn't a documentary I was like the
eighties eighties the new school can you
give an example because I don't know
what you're talking about Michael Myers
I'm talking about Freddy I'm Michael
Marley you know you're wrong I love him
one of the best ever I just think that
after 40 years there's not one of the
best songs many almost every Halloween
movie is terrible
well that's the point they've done the
same thing with him every time ho tilt
got it I heard you I know
quiet [ __ ] dressed like a mechanic
mask head tilt kill no one hears him
coming he doesn't run but he catches you
you hop on a flight you land in LA he's
there at the airport we get it Travis
sure you're a Halloween movie fan right
I loved it let me know what about the
franchise I wish you loved because it
was a mother that someone was trying to
kill yeah that's right Travis knew
exactly who the good guy was in this one
well like I like h2o yak is a danger
tainment do if Michael Meyers had not
tilted his head would you have been
disappointed oh that's what he's
supposed to do yeah I mean that and I
like I didn't think it's movie sucked at
all I liked it though some of them I
haven't heard you say one good thing I
thought the kill scenes were really good
this guy's some of the kill teams are
really good what about when he sprinkled
the teeth over the store great [ __ ]
scene great he killed the journalist
just because a great again Phenom II
that wasn't just to kill or you would
have killed our journalist or his head
against the [ __ ] glass and killed him
you're right he didn't kill the inlay
when he took the knife right to that
girl right she's looking out the window
yeah
yeah great for no reason by the way he
just went into her house and kill
hunters Glenn right in telling people
there was some great moments in I didn't
I didn't think it stung I'm just saying
I wanted one thing with Michael you
didn't like all the callbacks to the
original I did she disappears my god was
she doing out of time in this case is
something I'm healed I hated that she
looked out the window and sees him and
then she looked around and talking to
her dumb daughter on the steps or
whoever and then she puts her head
against the door huh and he breaks
through the door would come on man
that's Friday the 13th July Friday the
13th movies the first couple I did sure
the first one was terrifying terrifying
it's a good idea to make us afraid of
sleep understandable the original night
thinking about Kruger yeah yeah yeah
like I like that as a as a place for
fear right shirt be afraid when you're
awake okay seriously that kid yeah
they're all great scariest movie for you
in your life you know all honesty I
think the Exorcist even though it's
dated because of the effect it had on
people yeah is unlike any effect any
horror movies ever had never got me so I
would say white chicks incorporated
that's a horrifying one starring Jim
Norton rich Voss jim Florentine by the
way sorry pre-sale happening now for the
chip chip person podcast vocals is the
actual password so I'm sorry alright I'm
already getting notifications on my
phone people are quoting this
conversation and they're saying they're
referencing me saying no a movie monster
and you saying Dracula's not a
documentary dummy was the scariest movie
I ever saw as a kid I thought didn't
scare me no John Tom john-boy well you
weren't again I only I was in third
grade and I only saw the first cassette
there it was double VHS right I remember
I only saw the first one so I never saw
him die and I was at a sleepover party
with some friends and I was so petrified
I had one of my friends friends walk me
to the bathroom to pee and night that
movie was terrifying for kids frightened
and then I slept with my friend's
parents in their bed that night you know
yeah yeah that's weird man yeah and my
parents never questioned them about it
baby Jesus juice - I might have yeah
definitely - like it
was very uncomfortable you'd think that
my parents would like inquire do you
like the new it uh yeah I want to
penetrate I want to play that kid when
he's older obviously they do part two
yeah the little smartass kid from
stranger things yeah unfortunately I
think it's already cast yeah we could
work on that weekend people can die
that's right
[Laughter]